This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English, I'm Neil.
And I'm Sophie. What do you know about Cleopatra, Neil?
Well, she was Queen of Egypt quite a long time ago.
Anything else?
Uh, shh. Didn't she arrive for a meeting with Roman Emperor Julius Caesar rolled up in a carpet?
Or is that a Hollywood invention?
Some historical sources say she was rolled up in a carpet,
and others say she was hidden inside a linen sack.
Cleopatra is the subject of today's show.
She was the last Pharaoh to rule Egypt and is arguably the most famous female ruler in history.
And the most beautiful.
Well, the jury's out on that one, Neil, and that means people haven't decided yet.
Coins with Cleopatra's portrait on them, for example,
show her with a prominent nose and thin lips.
Prominent means noticeable, and in this case, I think it means large.
So, what were her attributes or main qualities then?
Cleopatra was a wily politician.
She made important alliances with Rome to protect her country and was ruthless in dealing with her enemies.
In this case, her siblings, who challenged her as sole ruler of Egypt.
Wily means clever, and sibling is another word for brother or sister.
Didn't she have her siblings murdered?
Yes, she was very ruthless, and that means without pity.
And today's quiz question is about her family.
Can you tell me, Neil, which country was Cleopatra's family originally from?
Is it A, Macedonia, B, Ethiopia, or C, Egypt?
I'm going for C, Egypt, the obvious answer.
Well, we'll find out if the obvious answer is the right one later on in the show.
But let's talk some more about Cleopatra's attributes.
She may not have been Hollywood gorgeous, but she spoke many languages and was highly educated
in philosophy, astronomy, mathematics, and oratory.
Here's Susan Walker, keeper of antiquities at the Ashmolian Museum at the University of Oxford
with more about this.
PooTark says that what was really remarkable about Cleopatra's, not so much her beauty,
as the intelligence of her company.
She had a very beautiful voice, which I think is a quality we perhaps underrate these days in
estimations of celebrity. And she clearly had masses of charisma,
sort of person who would light up a room. So enormous personal charm.
So the Roman historian PooTark wrote about Cleopatra's voice, her charisma and personal charm,
but not about her beauty. That's right. And charisma is, in other words, a strong power to attract
people. Cleopatra's voice was also considered very attractive. An attribute we underrate today,
according to Susan Walker. And underrate means to place too small a value on something.
Egyptian pharaohs were regarded as gods. And spectacle, or making a big visual impact,
was an important part of this. Cleopatra was very skilled at making grand
entrances, rolled up in a carpet for Caesar or dressed up as Venus on board a shimmering golden
barge for Mark Antony. He was a Roman politician in general. And even her death was spectacular.
She and Mark Antony had lost an important battle against another Roman general Octavian.
Mark Antony had fatally wounded himself when he heard mistakenly that Cleopatra was dead.
But before he died, he managed to get back to Cleopatra, who held him in her arms as he died in
her family tomb. Then she decided to take her own life. You make it sound like a Shakespearean tragedy.
Shakespeare did write a play about it. Now let's hear from Catherine Edwards,
professor of classics and ancient history at Berkbeck University of London about this tragic event.
She plans her own death. In this very sort of calculated manner, a manner that also seems to focus
on spectacle, yes again, that she takes her time, she has a feast, and then the basket of
figs arrives with the aspenet, or was it perhaps a poisoned hairpin? There's a certain amount of
uncertainty about the exact method of her death. I think most sources prefer the snake.
So, Catherine Edwards says, the fat surrounding Cleopatra's suicide aren't clear.
She may have used a snake to bite her, smuggled into her room in a basket of fruit,
but it may have been a poisoned hairpin, or simply a cup of poison. But she did it in a calculated
or carefully planned way. Okay, so the final curtain comes down on Cleopatra.
But what about the answer to today's quiz question, Sophie? Okay, I asked which country
was Cleopatra's family originally from? Is it A, Macedonia, B, Ethiopia, or C, Egypt?
And I said Egypt, of course it is. And that's the wrong answer, Nia. It's actually A, Macedonia.
Cleopatra was a member of the Tolamaic dynasty, a family of Macedonian Greek origin that ruled
Egypt after the death of Alexander the Great. You learn something new every day, talking of which
here are the words we learned in this program. The jury's out on something. Prominent attributes,
wily, sibling, ruthless, charisma, underrate, spectacle, calculated.
And that's the end of today's six minute English. Don't forget to join us again soon.
Goodbye. Bye-bye.